cold open just to let you know that the
pod con crowdfunding campaign will be
closing down very very soon pod con if
you don't know is an event that we did
last year in Seattle and we're doing it
again it's just for people who love
podcasts whether you make podcasts or
just really love listening to them it's
happening on January 19th and 20th in
Seattle and there will be tons of
amazing podcasts represented I'm gonna
do a list but it's gonna be incomplete
welcome to night Vale my brother my
brother and me 99% invisible the stoop
lore hello fan magic tavern Nancy Sam
Sanders from it's been a minute oh no
Ross and Carrie Demi and Miele from
punch up the jam and tons more we'll be
doing a live dear Hank and John and
there will be lots of other fun weird
cool things like live shows podcast
mashups performances panels ghost
stories and other good weirdness just go
to pod contains a whereas I prefer to
think of it Dear John and Hank it's a
comedy podcast for two brothers answer
your questions give you devious advice
and bring you all the week's news from
both Mars and AFC Wimbledon John yes
why were the Mongols so happy why were
the Mongols so happy Hank because they
were nomads I love this new opening bit
I love that you tell a dad joke and then
I took a share something that's good
this week so Jon what's good this week
besides my very good dad joke about
Mongols that was a very good joke Hank
do you remember the couple who we
tracked down their wedding website
through somewhat nefarious means and it
was an unfinished website and we made
fun of it yes I do it was it was not
great it almost seemed maybe possibly
incomplete and maybe we shouldn't have
mocked it right because they weren't
ready to share it yet we got a very nice
email from Josh explaining that they
just weren't done with their wedding
website which is why they hadn't told
anyone about it and it wasn't Josh's
fault that we tracked it down through
somewhat nefarious means anyway they are
now finished with their wedding website
and I just wanted to give you an update
Hank because it is the
greatest wedding website I have ever
seen in my entire life
like I don't know who designed this site
but I want them to design my new website
they have an app Hank they have an app
available in both the Apple Store and
the Google place okay and this is good
this but like can we set the bar lower
for just everything I just like I feel
like I feel like you guys are setting
the bar way too high I don't need it
I don't want it I don't need an app it's
a great wedding website their guide to
the Uniting party is hilarious they're
their stories about how they met each
other are so great and it's just all so
well done and as apology for the fact
that we tracked on your website before
you were ready Kathie and Josh Hank and
I have purchased you a fancy dinner at
the Eiffel Tower which by the way I
learned this week does have a bathroom
near the top of it but it's got pipes
all the way down to the bottom that's
good cuz you don't want to get up there
and be like I gotta poop there's a
countdown on there their wedding website
John it's counting down as I'm staring
at it yeah it's 214 days away how is
your website look this good
214 days out I just don't have time for
this well organized to be fair Hank they
probably weren't going to get it out
this quickly but then I made fun of them
they felt like their hand was forced so
are they going are they going to to
Paris for their honeymoon or did you
just see her just like you figure out
how to get there they are going to Paris
for their honeymoon and okay you have
bought them dinner at the Eiffel Tower
as an apology so congratulations to
Kathie and Josh both on their
forthcoming marriage and on a really
spectacular website Hank should we
answer some questions from our listeners
all right John this first question comes
from Nick who asks dear Hank and John I
rarely hear or see youtubers citing
their sources when clearly stating
information that came from somewhere
other than their own minds while I do
sometimes see a link to an article or a
video that holds the information from
which the youtuber got it
this doesn't appear to be common
practice
youtubers not required to practice any
sort of rules of source citation ya know
by what governing body mix I love I love
that I love it you think that's possible
because like when we're going to school
all the teachers are like you gotta cite
your sources here's to all the different
ways you could cite your sources gotta
use the Chicago Manual of style or
whatever and yeah and then you grew and
then you like make a youtube video and
there are no rules cuz it's the internet
and you can literally say anything
welcome to 2018 yeah I mean imagine if
everybody had to cite their sources on
Facebook there would be no Facebook oh
wait it would be way too much work the
entire the people who work for social
media companies talk about like the
barrier to too expression so like what
how can we lower the barrier to posting
they wanted to be very easy for new
content to be created because content is
the thing that makes the platform work
and so on Twitter they make it basically
so that any dumb thought that pops out
of your mind becomes useful enough for
you to be like well you know it's a
tweet and it's very easy to post same
thing with like Instagram stories or
snapchat stories the idea is like make
it so easy to create content that
everyone will do it and make like
putting a barrier in that that is uh
that is as boring and frustrating as
citing your sources ha good luck we
should add though that Nick in his email
cited all of his sources which I thought
was very impressive we try to do this in
crash course we don't always do it and
we especially didn't do it at the
beginning yeah but we we do think it's
important and we're trying to put more
of an emphasis on it in our educational
content because we need people to
understand that we didn't just make this
stuff up and that we're doing our best
not to just guess the reason it doesn't
happen on YouTube is because it's work
and a lot of times that work is
expensive and time-consuming and it
doesn't feel as central to the mission
as for instance making or animating the
video
right which is why there are all kinds
of signals in academia to force you to
do this because in in many ways like the
work isn't worthwhile unless you can
figure out you know unless you can build
on the work and you can't build on the
work without knowing where the
information came from
especially because sometimes information
turns out to not be good and if the
information came from somewhere and
you're not sure where and you can't
check and you can't see if like it has
since been known to not be good
information then you you cannot actually
build knowledge that way and right I
think that a good sign of credible
content on the Internet is that they do
cite their sources and you know we have
tried to do that more and we do it on
crash course but we certainly don't do
it every time on vlogbrothers just
because like it's work and we got other
stuff to do and it's not supposed to be
work it's supposed to be fun right Fogg
brothers must be we will not like citing
my sources I'm done with school
I cite my sources in informational
videos actually but I like that Nick is
basically saying I care and I think more
of us need to care and by the act of
caring the incentives will change so
thank you Nick
you're the hero we need if not the hero
we deserve the next question comes from
Naomi who writes dear John and Hank I
recently went to my local bookstore and
bought a used copy of an abundance of
katherines which I had already read well
thank you and I owe me for liking it
enough to purchase it when I got home I
opened it up to find a note that looked
like it had been typed on a typewriter
and it said hope you liked this book
smiley face PS you have an incredibly
mellifluous voice and then a phone
number oh my god I was very confused as
the stranger had left me their number in
a book and wanted me to call them I
looked up the number and it's from
Arkansas I'm opposed to calling strange
numbers but we have the same taste in
books so I don't know what to do help
not a Katherine Naomi
good John I so like first update is that
back in that when that book came out was
it yep was it that book uh no paper
towns
yeah it was paper town well but but we
had this thing where we had
people leave weave notes inside of John
Green books telling people like
basically a way to communicate in the
real world to like leave a comment and
they were called nerdfighter notes and I
had assumed that all of the nerdfighter
notes had been discovered by now but
apparently not apparently not although
it does seem weird to say PS you have an
incredibly mellifluous voice which it's
just presumptuous however I am gonna
call the phone number you're gonna call
the phone number he's gonna call the
phone number yeah but not with my phone
I'm no dummy I got a good [ __ ] shared
and hold on Sheridan wants to sit here
till I'm finished to make sure that I
don't misuse her phone which is totally
reasonable hold here we go we call him
the number Hank I don't know who I'm
calling that's probably not oh okay that
was fast
the mailbox is full its full by the way
this happens every time I call my
brother Hank green oh I don't know how
to empty my mailbox he doesn't answer
the phone and then I'm told that the
mailbox is full so I literally can't
leave him a message except to text him
but don't worry he doesn't reply to
texts how do you how do you delete voice
messages I just don't know like whyatt
I don't understand I don't know but look
look okay this is something I don't
understand
I can't a hat like I have gigabytes of
space on in my email why can't my
voicemails just be stored in the same
system so that I don't have to
constantly delete voicemails why why
don't know why don't I want to keep my
voicemails I don't understand just put
them on the Google Drive with all of the
other files in the cloud I can upload
literally anything I want to youtube but
I can't keep a freaking voice mail I am
glad that you have found something
really important to be outraged about
Hank because that does seem to me one of
the leading problems of 2018 that it is
difficult to store as many voice mails
as we would like I'm just upset that I
can't call this person and it appears
that we're never going to be in contact
ever again so it's a bummer it is a
bummer like like uh-uh missed
opportunity everybody that probably the
number isn't in service anymore or
they're just like me and don't know how
to don't know how to delete voicemails
this next question comes from Allison
who asks dear Hank and John I am
currently dating a very sweet guy and
it's all going very well however he
often compliments me by saying things
like I look beautiful my problem is I do
not feel like there's a socially
acceptable way for me to tell him that
he is also beautiful I realized that I
could tell him he is handsome but that
word feels awkward and formal I would
just break free of these laws of social
acceptability and say that he's
beautiful because he is but I don't want
to make him feel uncomfortable when I'm
trying to compliment him so I'm turning
to my two favorite podcasters for a help
not a STONER Allison what does that mean
is Allison stone or a thing who's
Allison stoner I think that she's on How
I Met Your Mother
no that's definitely not that's Alyson
Hannigan Alyson Stoner
is she's from Cheaper by the Dozen from
2003 also in multiple step she was on
The Suite Life of Zack and Cody yeah I
think she was in step up step up three
taken time streets and she was she was
in several different step ups but I'm
glad that Alyson Stoner born 1993 is a
great candidate for this week in Ryan's
at least John do you have any good
things for to call Alison's boyfriend I
would I would just go with hot that's
what I usually use or Hans's but I would
also not be afraid of beautiful what was
the second step up movie called oh god
the streets was it that way I think that
was the streets hold on I don't you the
streets she doesn't appear to have been
in the second one which was the best one
which is it was so good I feel bad I
feel bad if Alyson Stoner listens to
this podcast and she finds out that she
wasn't in what was by far the best step
up movie but she wasn't it's so hard to
get this man to focus he's 40 years old
everyone focus I am focused what is the
question I asked Catherine this question
I went to a source and I was like what
would you say if you ever wanted to tell
a man that he was attractive yeah
um and she said you got to go with fit
yeah isn't that what English people say
I like that I like fit I also like
handsome what's wrong with handsome it
doesn't seem that old-fashioned to me
although I guess I am technically an old
person so what do I know what about like
oh you're looking dapper today do you
know that the first step up movie has a
19 percent approval rating on Rotten
Tomatoes and the consensus states that
quote this trite teen romance has two
little plot and not enough dancing I
mean wrong on both counts sir
how did step up to the streets do step
up to the streets is only 27 percent
fresh on Rotten Tomatoes what are these
critics thinking step up to the streets
is one of the greatest films of all
frickin time I've watched it at least
two times and it has a 76% liked it
score from the audience which let's be
honest who cares what the critics think
and John do you think that there is
something deeper at play where we can't
call men beautiful where we feel like
that's weird do you want to get into it
not only do I think there's something
deeper at play Hank I think it is
actually related to the reason that 73%
of professional movie critics thought
that step up to the streets was a bad
movie I think we have all of these ideas
about what constitutes good and bad and
beautiful and I think that toxic
masculinity plays a role in what kind of
movies are treated as being high quality
movies and I think toxic masculinity
plays a role in what kind of people are
talked about as being beautiful like one
of the critics wrote this isn't a very
good movie but it's probably the best of
its kind which to me is just exactly
what's wrong with a certain strain of
criticism like to me the job of
criticism in art is not to say what is
high art what is properly good the job
is to say like what accomplishes what it
sets out to accomplish and is what it
sets out to accomplish interesting and
beautiful and the answer for step up to
this
streets is yes and yes absolutely it was
a beautiful movie and Alison's boyfriend
is also beautiful and but if you're
gonna make him uncomfortable saying it
you could just say you looking good
today sweetie I might say something like
if you were a step up movie you would be
step up to the streets baby this next
question comes from Brooklyn who asks
dear H and J an unforeseen circumstance
has occurred my cousin broke up with his
boyfriend they have been going out for
10 months the boyfriend got along with
the family super well and I became
fairly close with them bonding over
school and such he's three years older
than me same as my cousin and I'm not
really in the same social setting as
either of them mostly due to this age
difference but he's really nice
I really like talking to him but I think
it'll be awkward to hang out or talk to
him because I don't get out much anyway
not a boy not a bridge not a borough or
a Beckham Brooklyn what a great sign-off
yeah this is a fairly common problem in
the world where we have people enter our
lives because they're entering through
another person that has already our
lives but then they don't have that
relationship with that person anymore
and who do we pick or kit or do you have
to pick and sometimes you do yep
sometimes you do have to pick and and if
it's family
you got it probably God go with family
you do usually have to go with family
that said it doesn't seem clear to me
that in this situation Brooklyn does
have to pick
I feel like Brooklyn could text or email
this person and say hey I just or just
say hey how are you doing just check in
on them I think it's really nice to have
people check in on you and they might
respond they might not but at least it
puts the ball in their court and it lets
them know that you do care about them
separate from your relationship with
your cousin but what I would say very
strongly is if you have any romantic
interest in this person do not pursue
any relationship at all if you're
thinking well we can just be friends but
I do think that they're pretty cute nope
nope nope nope nope nope nope nope nope
nope nope nope nope nope
maybe you know I don't know how well you
remember the plot of stuff up to the
streets Hank but the whole story doesn't
happen if there isn't a little bit of
that that was okay I would like to
officially announce that as my last step
up to the streets reference for the
entire pod don't make promises you can't
keep this next question comes from Becky
who writes Dear John and Hank at the
turtles all the way down to her last
year my best friend and I made posters
for the show in Indianapolis we were
both very excited at the time but then
afterwards we realized where we a bit
too crazy now that we've gotten our
tickets for the absolutely remarkable
thing to her coming up in Indianapolis
we are wondering should we make posters
again please answer us we are stressed
out and don't want to be too
overwhelming uh make posters and also
encourage others so what you want to do
is bring everybody else up to your level
not go down to theirs right bring
everybody else up so organized poster
creation party times at your local
library I am strongly in favor of
posters Becky I will tell you a story
about early in my career early in my
career as a writer I did a signing with
a writer named Stephenie Meyer who wrote
the Twilight books and I hadn't met her
before and I wasn't very familiar with
her work it was right after the first
Twilight book had come out and we did
this scientist int gather with a little
event before where we all talked a
little bit about each of our books there
were like four authors there and in the
front row there were all these people
with handmade t-shirts about the world
of Twilight and I was so blown away by
that and I was so moved by it and I
remember thinking I don't write those
kind of books like I don't write the
kind of books that people get that
excited about and feel that passionately
about and I was just so blown away by
the passion of that fandom and the
excitement and I was honestly jealous of
it and then when Paper Towns came out I
saw for the first time people holding
posters wearing t-shirts people dressing
like Margo Roth Spiegelman making
t-shirts like the t-shirt that she had
in the book and it was one of that tour
was one of the best experiences of my
life for that reason so do not worry
that you are not being cool because that
kind of passion it's infectious and it
really makes the world better yeah and I
remember once I did a livestream in
between two tour stops and then I
arrived at the next tour stop and there
were people who had had made a handmade
t-shirts referencing the livestream that
I did the night before and that just
made me so happy yeah and and I think
that like that like showing people and
showing yourself how much you care about
something is it really is a net positive
for everybody involved so yeah go
overboard yeah especially if overboard
for you is making a poster which is just
really lovely yeah don't yeah don't go
so far overboard that you like build a
shrine I think that's the line do you
have candles that you keep lit all the
time that flicker in the face of Leonard
Nimoy or whatever that's that's too far
let's do you have to tone down your
Leonard Nimoy passion a little bit
agreed agreed
anything that could cause a fire hazard
in general is is overboard worship
though John I do
I do love Leonard Nimoy do you have
another question for us I do this one
comes from Sarah who writes Dear John
and Hank I grew up in a family that
doesn't listen to music quick at all oh
okay I grew up to the sounds of NPR
audiobooks and maybe the occasional
classical or Christian radio station now
that I've gotten older and have access
to music of my own I don't know where to
start there's so much music out there I
can relate to that
like I get on Spotify and I'm like man a
lot of people have made this stuff I
have no idea what to listen to people
have told me to just listen to different
genres and I'll be able to tell what I
like but I can't really pin down any
specific genres or bands that I like
more than others it's just all so new
and so good I guess my question is how
do you figure out what your musical
tastes are when there are infinite
options do you have any bands that you
recommend scrolling through Spotify
Sarah before John starts yes he has
bands to recommend but but but I what I
will say before John makes his
recommendation is I have a broad over
arching piece of advice which is to pick
and when you're younger it's so much
easier to pick because you are given
these signals that like this is the
thing we should be paying attention to
by your friend group by your culture by
the radio by whatever and like and you
know what's good and you don't have to
question it and but because we're a
little bit older now there's like oh
there's so much stuff there's all these
different layers to every genre and and
also like music has been happening for
the last thousand years so there's also
all that stuff that it's very difficult
to pick but I think it's really good and
I have a hard time doing this but I am
much happier about music when I pick
something to dive into for a little
while and spend some time like going
through a catalogue of an artist and
developing a deeper relationship with
with songs that I've heard not just a
few times but like dozens of times I'm
gonna recommend the mountain goat
they're really good band Sarah I think
that you'll like them they're the best
band in the whole world they they have
like 800 or 900 songs so you'll never be
out of new mountain goat songs or at
least not for a long time plus they're
always making new ones they're so great
I do really recommend the mountain goats
but I have to say I also listen to a lot
of jazz music I listen to a lot of New
Orleans brass big-band music I listen to
bluegrass music I I agree with Hank that
it's fun to dive deep it's fun for me
like it's a matter of going through
phases there's stuff that I like to
listen to what I'm running that's
different than the stuff I like to
listen to when I'm you know working but
I love that I I just the thing I loved
about this question Hank was Sara saying
it's all so new and so good yes music is
so good there is so much great music in
the world and we are so lucky to live in
an age of recorded music so that we can
actually listen to it even if we aren't
rich enough to be able to go to fancy
concerts John since you made your one
suggestion for one band I have to give
Sara a suggestion one band
for you to maybe dive deep on I'm gonna
go with with Fountains of Wayne I mean
Sarah and their new and their new hit
song Hank and John I've got it going on
and also a purple tank cuz just call it
it all the way back to year one of dear
Hank and John
so just to be absolutely clear about
this Sarah
Hank is kidding actually you know you
want to know a really good album if
you're just starting to listen to music
you want to know a really genuinely good
album to listen to because I think
soundtracks are good for that stuff
because it gives you a broad kind of
introduction to a bunch of different
kinds of music would be the soundtrack
for step up to the streets it's got yeah
low by that song it's such a good song
it's one of Henry's favorite songs
actually so I hear it all the time
there's two Missy Elliott songs on it I
think that Missy Elliott is maybe the
pop music artist that will be listening
to in like the 23rd century assuming
there are still humans I think that
she's like the the Beethoven of right
now there's all kinds of great songs
t-pain church t-pain's church is a that
is an unbearable song like you hear it
and you cannot do anything but move it's
so good oh they called back Hank they
called back they called back they called
back that callback callback callback
Sheridan just came in the room they
called back I'm calling them now I'm
calling now I'm calling now do they only
turn their phone on occasionally alright
when they call the next time will you
just answer and bring it in to me it's
real weird this is weird
I have a conspiracy theory and I'm a
little worried about Sheridan cuz it's
her phone you know I guess one last
thing I'll say to Sarah is that it's
it's good to like popular music it's
popular for a reason
and and you can focus in on that and
it's not like it's not like it's not
cool till this
the pop music it's not all popular for a
reason but I hear yeah I think it's I
think there's always a reason John it's
just not always the best reason this
next question comes from Amanda who asks
dear Hank and John you know there's a
finite amount of water on earth the same
water discontinuously flows through the
water cycle and the amount of water on
earth stays the same but what about what
meteors are comets into the atmosphere
and occasionally hit earth aren't they
just rocks and ice does that mean that
new water is introduced to earth does
the amount of water on earth increase if
ever so slightly
I hope this question isn't too demanding
dftba amanda that's some hard work you
did there I think that when amanda is
like in a work situation she says things
like I don't want to make a demand but
it's like what our colleagues caller
right oh there's demand uh-huh full of
demands Hank does the amount of water on
earth go up when we get hit by big water
meteors it does it does in fact there is
some there is some different models that
are that have run and lots of people are
still you know working on this problem
but current research indicates that if
we didn't have that source of external
water that there wouldn't be much water
on earth that it would have all been
blown off by the solar wind by now and
so we need new inputs of water or else
we're in trouble so especially there was
a period of time where a lot of icy
bodies hit earth and and that and
probably a lot of the water that's on
earth right now was not part of the
initial formation of earth it arrived a
little later so should I be rooting for
us to get hit by water meteors now no
nope no okay no all right I'll note
against that yep definitely root against
large meteor strikes if you're gonna if
there's like a I don't know I don't know
how much it matters how strongly people
support one team or another
like if one teams fans are just really
gung-ho and the other ones are very
quiet if that's actually good for the
team but I do know that if we just sit
here and think really hard about not
getting hit by a meteor it's not gonna
help
yeah no that's the great thing about
getting hit by a meteor nothing will
help it's just a nice pleasant reminder
that we are not in control we're in
control of a lot of things John mm-hmm
I'm in control apparently of my
voicemail inbox which hold on I'm gonna
I'm gonna try that I'm gonna try that
number again oh I can't I can't force I
don't know Sheridan's password if you
could only answer the phone okay I can
only answer the phone I think this next
question comes from timoni who asks dear
John and Hank since you guys don't talk
about death at all anymore on this
comedy podcast about death I need to ask
you about death in the distant future
how will humans die what kind of
inventions will there be for death well
hopefully we won't invent any new
inventions for death but that we're
getting this question right after the
question where we went straight meteor
strike yeah
that wouldn't necessarily result in
broad death would it uh depends on what
you mean by broad death and depends on
what you mean by meteor strike I'm
thinking just like an ice-water meteor
you know that just drops a bunch of nice
delicious clean space water it turns out
that it doesn't really matter what the
meteor is well it does matter what the
meteor is made of but an icy meteor it
can do a hole like a whole lot of damage
it just make a nice like space lake you
just want a big wet one just rains on
down will everyone know me a bass bass
kiss well I want the solar system to
give me a good good wet tongue II kiss
French space kisses will everyone know
the date of their death when they're
born will death be fun
deathly curious to know me I don't think
I like I like where tete huerta mommy's
coming from the
yeah why not I like I like it because
it's like here are a couple examples of
dystopias everybody is just looking
forward to it they're like oh god did
you know I get to die on Tuesday I have
no idea how our relationship to death
will change as lives get longer and
healthier I think it has already changed
a lot though in the sense that death
used to be something that was
unavoidable and part of everyday life in
a way that in the rich world at least it
isn't anymore well what I my only big
guess is that as we get better at living
longer it will be very bad if that isn't
distributed fairly equally among
societies yes well it already is very
bad I would say yes but it will it will
get much worse and and that that that is
my most that is my biggest concern about
like like lifespan extension is that is
that will give it to our dogs before we
give it to other people and that will be
really bad not just for the people who
aren't getting the treatments but also
for the people who died in the
revolution yeah I think I agree I think
one of the biggest challenges with new
technologies that improve human life is
having them be shared among all humans
indeed John which is why this podcast is
brought to you in part by a an
organization that doesn't get to sponsor
a ton of stuff all that often so wait
we're glad that they're here sponsoring
us today it's justice just having things
that should be available to all people
be available to more people yeah it's a
little troubling to me that justice
doesn't have as big a marketing budget
as for instance tide but what can you do
what can you today's podcast is also
brought to you by Leonard Nimoy Leonard
Nimoy it's okay to worship Him just not
with candles it's a fire hazard this
podcast is also brought to you by music
it's a bunch of noises but real good and
lastly today's podcast is brought to you
of course by step up to the street step
up to the streets the greatest of all
step up movies although I actually
thought step up 3d
movie as well we also have a project for
awesome message from Mike good nice on
most things to a Hank John and the last
ease and all of the friends I have made
through nerdfighteria thank you for
inspiring me to be more positive
compassionate loving and grateful every
day thank you for making this community
a solace I can turn to
day or night when I'm feeling lonely or
social happy or sad whether we've met in
person or I've never met you in a
physical space thank you for being in my
life and letting me be a small part of
yours you know it's also a good dance
movie ah
breakin 2 electric Boogaloo that's what
I was gonna say yeah well we're you know
we're roughly the same age oh my god I
loved that movie
oh I wonder if it holds up there's only
one way to find out John and that's to
do a break into electric Boogaloo
project for awesome commentary perk with
Hank and John it's on Netflix it's on
Netflix it's on Netflix we could watch
it tonight let's just let's livestream
let's do it tonight
well I actually tonight I'm busy let's
do it soon okay okay I bet it's gonna be
really good all right
I'm so excited about this this is such
good news all right break into electric
Boogaloo which I'm sure holds up perfect
I mean I loved it so much oh god I liked
it so much it must be good it was the
grease - was there a break-in one you
know I don't think there was smart smart
smart to start with the sequel oh wow it
doesn't have a great IMDB rating John
well that doesn't mean that it's not a
good movie it just means that movie
snobs don't like it there was a break-in
there was break-in and then there was
break-in - electric Boogaloo but it
looks like breakin 2 was much more
popular than than breakin they both came
out in the same year of course I mean
when you have a hit
follow it up man holy moly
that was fast all right John this next
question comes from Grace who asks dear
Hank and John how do forecasters know
that it's going to rain in ten days
amazing grace they don't it is amazing
they don't it's true that they don't
sure they don't know
but they do have they do have some
ability to predict beyond flipping a
coin which is pretty pretty cool yeah
but it's not that much better than
flipping a coin ten days that's true
five days out though is actually like
we've gotten to the point where five
days out is extremely accurate compared
to where we were even ten years ago and
that is really like five days is a long
time to have yeah even somewhat accurate
forecasts of temperature of wind speed
of rain yep
it's really it's really amazing and how
do we do that we do it with lots of
computer models very powerful computers
and lots and lots of inputs so
constantly updating from weather
stations all over the place what every
condition is from barometric pressure to
wind speed to humidity to and like and
like knowing where things are going to
move so we can model out into the future
right and we also have lots of data from
history yeah to work with as well yeah
for a little bit of context when Hank
and I were kids weather forecasts were
often wrong about like that day like
they'd be wrong about whether or not it
was going to rain in two hours yeah yeah
and it's hard when it's like spotty and
so it's gonna rain in one place in your
in your coverage area and not and not in
another place in that coverage area but
but it is amazing but I will say that
it's probably we're bumping up against
some of the limits of what we can
forecast because ultimately some of this
does come down to chaos and randomness
and just like the intricacies of how a
cloud can form might affect you know
what what's gonna happen ten days from
now and that really asked like that's
the kind of thing that we so far can't
model perfectly and probably won't be
able to model perfectly so a little bit
bumping against what's possible but it's
really good what we have is pretty great
hey I have some breaking news yeah and
it's not it's not that the person I
called is called back tank they have it
that's what
it's that we've just gotten an email
from dr. Karl vine ond who writes dear
John and Hank at the beginning of
episode 150 you were wondering about
Eiffel Tower sized piles of poop and how
long they would take to build it seemed
solvable so I did solve it and then
there is a PDF that is only two pages
long and it begins if this thing is
going to be freestanding
droppings just drop on a pile without
structural support it will eventually
form a cone the volume V of the cone of
base radius R and height H can be
computed as and then goes on in
incredible astonishing detail to explore
how long it would take people to make a
cone of poop as tall as the Eiffel Tower
and the answer is around 120,000 years
[Applause]
well that's that's way longer than I
thought yep and that's if every visitor
dropped an average human daily
defecation worth of poop on the pile
every person visiting the Eiffel Tower
well that's great news 7 million
visitors yearly a hundred and twenty
thousand years that's wonderful news man
that's great news I'm so glad I don't
know why it's good news it just feels
like good news it does it feels like the
world has gotten more interesting
because now I know how long it would
take the visitors of the Eiffel Tower to
make an Eiffel Tower of poo
yeah and also that it would take a long
long time yeah I know probably I what I
what is the radius of that cone John
because it's gotta be probably gonna be
wider than it is tall I'm gonna be
honest I don't understand a lot of the
calculations in this document so I'm not
sure I can answer that question
ok well we'll put that one up on the
patreon for everybody to see probably
also tweeted out because it sounds
pretty amazing yeah it's pretty great
Thank You Karl we appreciate it Hank
let's get to the all-important news from
Mars and AFC Wimbledon don't worry I'll
start yeah it seems according to my my
phone which tells me AFC Wimbledon
scores now because I have apparently
tweeted about it enough
ah it's good news we're undefeated we
haven't lost all season it's incredible
if we continue at this rate we'll have
not just the greatest season in AFC
Wimbledon's history but maybe one of the
greatest seasons in football history AFC
Wimbledon had a nil nil draw with
Coventry and that really we should have
won there should have been a penalty
called in the last minute of the game
but also we just had a ton of good
opportunities and the way that we were
playing was I thought really promising
and then in the League Cup
we were one-nil down to Portsmouth in
the second half when Joe Piggott scored
a goal to make it a tie I think Joe
Pickett is comfortable with piggie jokes
because that's his Twitter handle it's
like piggy something but okay the AFC
Wimbledon fans have taken to saying feed
the pig and he will score and indeed it
does seem that if you feed Joe Pinkett
enough crosses he will score so Joe
Pickett scored made it 1-1 and then
there was an own goal in the 88th minute
my favorite kind of goal and AFC
Wimbledon prevailed to 1 1 nil down to 2
1 up so that's a pretty great result
taken on Barnsley this weekend I don't
know I'm feeling really optimistic that
might come back to haunt me I should
never feel optimistic but I am I can't
lie I'm excited we're currently sitting
ninth in the league one table which I'll
take that all day long
Wow that's that's pretty amazing so
there are teams who are less who are
more undefeated more undefeated than you
then there are eight teams more
undefeated than us yes several of which
won both of their opening two games but
they're just bragging all right great
news keep it up I'm glad that the team
is playing as a as a team and Joey pigs
is getting his his uh his daily
allowance as they say what's the news
from Mars this week well a news from
Mars is still tense and not great as the
dust storm that has been going on for
the last month or two months already now
is finally settling a little bit but
opportunity the rover that's been on
Mars for almost 15 years
is it has not woken up yet so it's been
it's been sixty to sixty well when this
when this podcast comes out it will have
been almost 70 days since since
opportunity was last heard from and
hopefully by the time the podcast comes
out we'll hear something but it's
starting to feel a little bit like we
might not hear something because that's
a really long time to go with no power
so it's a solar-powered Rover the
basically the dust storm was thick
enough that it was nighttime no power
was getting to it and the battery may
have frozen in that time because one of
the things that the that the solar
panels do is actually warm the battery
so that it doesn't freeze this is so
they have to get a certain amount of
sunlight or the battery can freeze right
because it's very cold on Mars and then
you can't recharge the battery because
then the battery cannot function to wake
the rover up so when opportunity first
landed on Mars they had a song that they
would play in the in Mission Control
every morning because everybody was so
amped up and excited so the real news
from Mars is that they have started to
do this again to keep morale up in the
room because everybody's a little bummed
but also but also to you know just to
try and wake wake the wake the rover up
so they've actually released a playlist
on Spotify of some of the songs that
they are playing which include wake me
up before you go-go Club the trooper
from iron maple does dust in the wind
from Kansas here comes the Sun by the
Beatles it's a dog man oh that's
adorable oh man I hope it wakes up but
even if it doesn't what an
accomplishment to have a solar-powered
battery working for 15 years on Mars let
alone all the other things that had to
work for it to talk to us all those
years it's pretty amazing and and the
team still is holding out hope and they
still are sending a little message every
day to try and try and wake it up and
give it a little beep and say can you
beat back for us and so far no back beep
but frankly this this mission was a wake
was planned to last 90 days and that
would have been considered a success so
15 years on the on the red planet is is
wonderful but we will continue have
updates for you here at dear Hank and
John if you want to stay updated on how
how opportunity's doing well Hank thank
you for the update from Mars and indeed
thank you for Pauling with me what did
we learn today oh gosh well we learned
at the Eiffel Tower of poop it's gonna
take a while
yeah 120,000 years half of human history
so far oh man we got to get more people
visiting the Eiffel Towers what I've
learned
we've learned that step up to is a
really wonderful movie and anybody who
doesn't think so is wrong period end of
story
we've learned that if you got a lean
into your enthusiasm and bring people up
to where you are not meet them down
there and lastly we learned that there
is so much music and it is so good John
thank you for prodding with me as always
you can email us your questions and we
really appreciate when you do that
because it's how we make the podcast you
can do that I Hank and John at gmail.com
I am Hank green on Twitter John is John
Green this podcast is edited by the
indefatigable Nick Jenkins it's produced
by rosianna halse rojas and Sheridan
Gibson our head of community and
communications Victoria Buon Giorno the
music that you're listening to right now
and at the beginning of the podcast is
by gunnarolla thank you again for
listening and as they say in our
hometown don't forget to be awesome I'm
back here at the end of the episode with
your final reminder that the pod can
campaign is ending very soon so if you
think you can support it in these final
hours before it ends whether you can
make it to the event or you want to get
the $30 digital attendance which will
deliver the entire conference to the
podcast app of your choice you can go to
pod can calm now or whenever you get
home don't do it while you're driving